the best moments from the 2018 Teen
Choice Awards and what you didn't see on
TV it is Monday guys I am literally
fresh off a plane from a trip to Oregon
my voice is shot and it's hat day but I
hope you guys had a fun weekend because
the Stars of Riverdale were busy
enjoying the fruits of their labor at
the Teen Choice Awards on Sunday the
cast rolled in to the award show looking
like the hottest squad on television I
mean look they all turned out looks but
can we talk about best dressed of the
night my boy KJ Appa in this salmon pink
cashmere two-piece looking oh so dapper
next to his on an off-screen buddy Cole
Sprouse on the red carpet dying for that
look now inside the Riverdale hunk
photobomb Cole and his on and off-screen
love Lily Reinhart they won choice TV
ship KJ shared the same pic on Instagram
writing no one's safe gotta say it was a
solid and I overall for the Riverdale
residents they received the most
nominations of any other show and took
home 9 surfboard trophies including
choice drama TV show it looked like such
a fun night in our very own lauren zima
was on the hot pink carpet yesterday
that's where we got an update from fifth
Harmony's Lauren her eggie about life
after 5 H and where things stand with
her and the girls take a look I like you
look at this rope moment yeah sexy yeah
you know always got out a little sexy to
it nominated tonight right new music
what can you tease for us about the new
music well I have a some music coming up
very soon I've just been working just
been in the studio writing very present
kind of sonically with everything that
I've been creating so it's been cool to
just kind of delve into my own self
explorative worlds we saw an Armani and
Camila reunite a little bit how are
things there you talked to her at all
her how you guys doing I think
now we haven't really spoken or anything
yeah but it's probably like each other
what are you moving forward with your
solo crew working on your stuff what do
you want for yourself like what do you
see as the vibe of what you want to put
out I think I want to say I've just been
focusing on songwriting a lot like just
putting out my vision and putting out my
words and whatever it is that I wanted
to just say and what I've been wanting
to say for a while
it's very self expressive I like what
you've been wanting to say for a while
like what does that mean what inspires
you or what is what you've been wanting
just different things about my life
things that I've gone through you know
edit any songwriter who is anybody else
getting the vibe that Lauren and the
rest of the girls are probably over
being asked about harmony let's see who
puts out some solo stuff first I think
they're chomping at the bit I mean while
there's still tension between Anna
Kendrick and Ryan Reynolds y'all Anna's
keeping her feud with the Deadpool star
alive and well as she beat him for
choice Twitter last night I have so much
fun on Twitter and I know that Mindy and
commands have were nominated and also I
know that Bryan Reynolds was nominated
so in your face Ryan
[Music]
their ongoing jobs via social media all
started with Ryan and his wife Blake
Lively were trolling each other on
Instagram if you remember Blake said
this about her a simple favorite co-star
Anna Kendrick is the hotter female luer
version of my husband so would it really
count as cheating well that's when Anna
chimed in and wrote I let Ryan have
Deadpool he can give me this so what is
Ryan really think about Anna coming to
steal his wife here's what he had to say
about it when II tease Kevin Frazier
asked him at Comic Con Anna Kendrick
apparently loves your wife and feels
like she gave you Deadpool so she should
have your wife like that
Wow she wants to take my wife yes I know
a lot of guys that would be fine with
that but not me I would like to hang on
to her yeah please let's not do that I
can't think of sighs I mean she would be
so well taken care of with Anna though I
think you know got that we got the goods
yeah I know something tells me this is
only the beginning of this friendly
rivalry between Ryan and Anna but that's
it for today guys thanks for watching
and all you river babes share this video
and give riverdale the love they deserve
okay and while you're at it be sure to
check out our latest live interview with
singer Asher Angel he dishes on his
relationship status for all you asking
we saw your comment right see you guys
tomorrow